Nhưng mà hãy chuyện là khi mà các bạn tàu đen em đừng có chủ quan
Là ngay từ khi em đi phần nông đá bị đi phần nữa rồi
Nhưng có thể điểm phần biết a đốt các khóc
Còn không tính cái trường hả mà tôi đã đi phần hết
Sông vi cùng là đến gái bản đi phần nữa nhá
Điều không ta có lạc em mồ đen nhận này
Nà xưa lâu đi phần đầu là nát không phần bị đi phần đi phần đi phần
Các hốt đất thì khởi này
Xe West Bún này xưa hải chưa phần đi phần đi phần
A đốt đất thì u su hoa này
Nen nhận luôn là ngay trở đầu đi phần luôn
Còn em mà thì gạch em mà này thì cảm hai cái cách
Chứ này và anh yêu nghềm các đều bị đi phần nghề trở đầu
Nó nước không được đi phần nghề trở đầu
Vong các biểu rồi dân nhá các cộng phụ đi phần này